good afternoon cs19 how are you guys
doing today
fantastic that's what I like to hear
um
we have a wonderful wonderful class
ahead of us we're going to learn a very
critical idea once again we're going to
be learning about continuous random
variables this is cs109 before I jump
into things I this is a random photo of
my baby but I was just like heart melted
and I just thought I would share which
is really not the important thing though
maybe the important thing is it's a
Friday so I like to start Fridays with
just a nice story from Life
um
and the story I was going to tell you is
actually not related to this photo
um though I guess the short story is
like my day starts normally at six again
this morning I started at 5 45 a.m I
like feed the baby I dance party with
the baby this is like such we do she
calls it Yoda but she means yoga into
like we're gonna do our stretches it's a
fun way to start I recommend it anyways
but the story I was going to tell you
guys today was actually an interesting
story from my own life
um you guys may or may not know this but
I am legally blind in one eye and the
story behind that is quite interesting
uh when I was 11 years old I was living
in uh Kenny at the time and I I believe
I was with my parents and they were like
pointing something out and I was like
should I look out of my good eye or my
bad eye and my parents like what like
you're not supposed to have a good eye
in your mouth I thought everyone had one
uh and so I was like yeah I can't see on
my left eye and they're like we should
actually probably look into that
um a long story short something happened
to my left eye it was a disease and not
contagious don't worry
but the thing that happened to my left
eye was gonna happen to my right eye and
eventually a doctor in Nairobi figured
out exactly what it was and and they
figured out how to get me the solution
it was a little late for my left eye
though because it'd been bad for a long
time but then at one point my vision my
right eye went as well but because this
doctor had figured out what had gone
wrong they gave me the solution which is
an injection into the eye which is not
the most fun thing but you know I get to
see because of it uh he was able to give
me that solution exactly when I needed
it so I was able to keep Vision in my
right eye and I can see just 2020 out of
my right eye and you know on some level
in the left eye continues to be a pain
because it's been so long without being
treated it just like causes all it's my
problem child I
um and despite the fact that this has
been something I've had to deal with my
entire life and of course it'd probably
be more fun to see out of both eyes
and there's always the risk that I will
go blind it has been the most wonderful
silver lining in my life and I don't
know how to express it but I'm going to
try
there is something about being a middle
schooler where it's hard to appreciate
life like you just like oh middle school
is hard but I had this weird experience
at Middle School where I was like whoa
I'm supposed to not be able to have one
of these primary senses and yet I do and
so I have this appreciation that was a
big part of my life uh when you know I
there's a lot about middle school not to
appreciate and then there's other silver
lines that have come from it I certainly
feel like I I really do a lot of things
much better and a really small Silver
Lining is
I came to Stanford and of course there's
doctors helping me to make sure it
doesn't happen to my right eye and to
keep track of the left eye and there's
this time when this doctor is about to
do surgery on my eye he's doing like a
pre-op he's talking it's like oh what'd
you do I'm like oh you know I'm a uh I
was a PhD student at the time so I'm a
PhD student he's like oh what do you
study I'm like I study um artificial
intelligence like
tell me more and then of course because
the Stanford we started a collaboration
we've written like three scientific
papers together we just like have a good
time we like nerd out about eyes and and
probability and it's just been the most
fun Stanford experience so there's
really
the strange disease I have somehow been
a nice little light in my life and I
think one day my vision might just go
and I still believe when that happens
I'll still feel like okay that's the
cards I've dealt and it's been such a
blessing in such a lot of different ways
so anyways that's my Friday story fruit
of the random tree as my friend would
call it and that's the only connection I
have to cs109
I have a hook for you guys today this is
an extension of a problem we thought
about on Wednesday so on Wednesday we
learned about the poisson distribution
and we can ask ourselves what's the
probability of certain numbers of
earthquakes within a year
but there's a different spin on that
problem it was probably more relevant to
us we want to know what the probably at
Stanford of an earthquake within the
next four years and as that slight
difference spin will lead to a different
answer it's going to force us to
understand continuous uh probability uh
problem probabilities over continuous
space
okay
um oh quick question does anyone know
what this is a photo of
yeah at Stanford and there's like mem2
but it's got this weird tower and this
is like from the front of the quad and
it's got this this strange shape to it
and that's what Stanford looked like
before 1906 when there was a magnitude
seven point Earth eight earthquake which
took down this Tower and took down this
gate at the beginning of Stanford
okay well we're going to want to be able
to answer questions like that but of
course we have to learn some new things
to get there so let's learn some new
things and it's going to build on some
old Concepts we've had certainly we're
in this part of cs109 or one of the core
things for you to learn is this idea of
random variables and the first random
variable we learned was the binomial
random variable it's a metaphor that
comes from coin flips imagine if you
have n independent coin flips every coin
flip has the same probability of being
heads the random variable is going to
represent the number of heads you got in
the more General story it's the number
of successes within an independent
trials such a useful thing that we've
called it the binomial random variable
as soon as you define something to be
binomial random variable you inherit a
probably Mass function exploitation
variance we've gotten very good at this
it also has like the little sister the
Bernoulli random variable which is like
a binomial with just one coin flip more
useful for proofs later on
then on Wednesday we bumped it up a
notch we said let's learn a new random
variable we learned one of the most
beautiful interesting natural random
variables the poisson random variable
which says if you think about a fixed
amount of time what's the probability of
getting exactly K requests and the
magical story from Wednesday and if you
missed Wednesday class that's an
incredible one to go check out it's that
if you just give me an average number of
equate of requests per minute
because of the poisson process and all
the things that we can derive with
mathematics we can know the full
probability Mass function for the number
of events within one fixed time frame
that's so much that you get from so
little if you just tell me a rate you
immediately inherit this beautiful graph
um and all of this is on the course
website you know we have all these
random variables that we've learned
about today's goal though is to change
your understanding of random variables
from I'm going to drive them one at a
time to let's say somebody tells me
about a new random variable can I learn
it quickly and can I incorporate many
random variables into my vocabulary So
today we're going to learn not one
random variable not two random variables
but we're going to learn one two three
four random variables in one day the
learning goal really is then how can you
learn a new random variable
one of the points of random variables
you don't have to redrive all the math
to use it if somebody says this is a
random variable you get to inherit all
the math that they've done and I want
you guys to be able to work with random
variables that you haven't derived and
let me give you a very real situation
from your future
U has gone deeper into computer science
you are learning more you are thriving
having a great time and learning about
servers
well a big thing for servers is how long
a request has to wait in a waiting area
area before it gets served and if you
learn about it one of the most popular
algorithms is this md1q
and in md1q if you learn about it they
talk about how long a request is going
to be in the queue and they talk about
it as being distributed as a Borel with
parameter mu and 0.2 and at this point
you're like I took 109 and they never
taught me the Borel hopefully what we
teach you at this point isn't every
single distribution but rather how to
learn new distributions quickly so if
you looked up the Boreal Distribution on
Wikipedia it would give you all this
information and from this information it
would give you all the most critical
things and after 109 I want you to be
able to read this Wikipedia page and
know exactly what you need to be able to
follow along the conversation about the
md1 algorithm
what you really need to know is the
story what leads to it that's the
equivalent of a binomial is n coin flips
so a boreal has a story you should
understand that and then
you want to understand these equations
too a probability Mass function that's
the relationship between the values the
Boreal could take on and its probability
you want to know the mean and the
variance and Wikipedia gives all those
to you you might want to go drive them
yourself but more likely than not you
just want to understand this algorithm
and you might be using these equations
without derivation
so does that sound good there is a
learning goal for you guys future you is
going to be so appreciative that you uh
worked on the this learning goal today
okay
sound fun
everyone's curious about servers now
aren't they okay good times
so this is our goal for today we're
going to flesh out all of these random
variables you already know a Bernoulli
and binomial but I'm now going to teach
you uh or in Plus on but I'm not going
to teach you a geometric and a negative
binomial and then we're going to learn
an exponential
ready for it we're going to do two
quickly and your goal is to incorporate
them into your vocabulary random
variables so that we can start to solve
problems
okay geometric random variable if I
could give you a metaphor imagine a
Pokeball if you don't know what a
Pokeball is it's unrelated to the food
it's like this little thing that you
throw and you catch a Pokemon and you
throw it and you might catch a Pokemon
or you might not so you might have to
throw a whole bunch of pokeballs before
you catch a Pokemon if that's not
working for you then how about this
a geometric random variable is one
that's distributed as a geo with
probability p
and here's the narrative
it's the number of independent trials
until your first success
p is going to be the probability of
success on every single try
so the one way of reading this is coin
flips it's like a binomial says you have
n coin flips how many heads did you get
a geometric says how many times did you
have to flip that coin
until you got your first heads
it solves a slightly different problem
though related so you might say like you
know how many
um how many
server requests do I have to send before
one lands or how many pokeballs do I
have to throw before I get a Pokemon
it can take on the values one two three
up to Infinity has to be discrete
because you can't flip a coin 2.5 times
and why can't it be zero
a lot of our other random variables
could be zero what's wrong with making
this one zero
how are you going to get of heads if you
flip the coin zero times come on not
gonna work so very good point can't be
zero
I am going to point out this Pro tip if
you're learning a new random variable
thinking about the values it can take on
is such a grounding way to get yourself
oriented and think about why can't it
take on 2.5 why can't it take on zero
so as soon as you buy this story you
could then go and drive it this is one
you definitely could have derived
yourself you know what's the probability
that it takes you n coin flips to get
ahead
well that means you've got n minus 1
Tails followed by head you could have
derived this probably Mass function
it would have been a little bit more
annoying though to derive expectation
and variance maybe expectation is not so
bad but variance certainly would have
been quite a lot of work if you wanted
to drive it from scratch
so I'm giving you a brand new random
variable and anytime you feel that you
can match this narrative you have these
three tools you can work with does that
sound good
because I'm not going to stop there I
wrote it down over here so you can
follow along I'm going to introduce you
to one more before we start solving
problems
you're like I don't care about catching
one Pokemon I want to catch them all so
the negative binomial that's awful
it's how many independent trials not
until one success but until our
successes so it's like how many times
you have to flip a coin until you get r
heads and there's some problems that
really nicely fit this narrative
again we're gonna have the coin metaphor
where p is the probability of success on
each trial they're all independent every
trial has the same probably P of giving
you a heads in this case what's the
problem that x equals n
well if you say like five here you're
saying what's it probably took five coin
flips in order to get our successes
hopefully R is something like three less
than five
well you have all these different places
where you can put your successes you
have the probability of success the
probability of failure
um and you know you could go and think
about driving this but the point of
today's class is to be able to use
something that someone else's drive for
you
so as soon as somebody gives you a
random variable
you have the valid numbers it can take
on you have the probability Mass
function that's the relationship between
assignments and probabilities
and you get expectation and variance
okay now do you have to memorize all
these no cs109's midterm and final will
be open book anytime in the future when
you need to go references they will be
somewhere and for actually one of the
places uh one of the places that you can
find them if you go to the course reader
I made this section called random
variable reference and you can just go
see each of your favorite random
variables and you can be like oh hey
um that negative binomial here's what it
looks like you can put in different
values for r
you can put in different values for p
you can see the probably Mass function
expectation variance you don't have to
memorize them you need to know
conceptually what all these things are
you have to know what pmf is expectation
variance and you need to know how to
match the real world to the stories that
it tells
does that sound good yes
subscribe again
ah so there yes let me try and tell you
the story uh and talk about how they're
different
in a binomial you declare ahead of times
how many times you'll flip a coin you
say I'm going to flip it 10 times and I
care about how many heads it's a
different situation for the negative
binomial negative binomial says you're
not going to just do 10 you're going to
keep going and you'll keep going until
you get r
this number counts number of successes
this counts trials until successes
so they're both talking about coins
they're just counting different numbers
they're representing different values uh
based on those coins yes
oh that is such a good question I think
it has to do with the probability Mass
function because it has
um
binomial coefficient in it but
let me double check I'm pretty sure
that's it but I haven't checked that I
think I asked that question myself like
10 years ago I can't be positive that's
exactly it uh would you mind double
checking let us know if I got it wrong
cheers
okay question
exactly the probability that we're
covering the probability of
like with success
so in this case you tell me the
probability of a heads so the parameters
are what you tell me and what I'm
calculating are these things so you tell
me what's the chance of getting ahead
and I tell you what's the chance of a
certain number of Trials until our
successes
so you know this probability Mass
function if you see probability let's
say x is a negative binomial x equals
three
that's a probability question it's
asking what's the chance that the trials
until our successes takes on the value
of three
good question and it's assuming that X
was defined and when you define X's you
had to say two things
you had to say
how many successes are you looking for
so I'm looking for say like two
successes
that's r
and you have to say the probability of
success on every single child if it's a
coin maybe it's one half
yes it's very deep reason why the
expectation and variance of the negative
binomial are exactly our times the
expectation experience of the geometric
random variable there is a deep reason
we're going to get into the derivation
uh at some point but just to give you a
little bit of a hint
if x is a geometric
let's say x i is a geometric you can
think of Y which is a negative binomial
you can say Y is the sum
of X I's so it's like time until your
first success plus time until your next
success time will tell you so it's a sum
of random variables and because it has
this property lots of parallels will
show up but if you didn't follow along
on that not that important but it would
be helpful if you want to do derivation
more questions I love these questions
this is great yes
the value of R here it takes a maximum
value of anything
yeah it kind of flips a little bit I
would say n takes on a maximum value of
R because R is how many successes you're
looking for
oh wait sorry sorry
um no n must be larger than R sorry R is
how many successes you're looking for n
is your number of Trials number of
Trials must be greater than number of
successes second equator or greater than
equal it could be greater than equal to
like if you're looking for let's say R
is three I'm saying how many trials
until three successes n is how many
trials I ran and it could be three it
could be three you're just like success
success success drop mic I'm out of here
totally possible
okay now the interesting thing here is
I'm going to give you some problems
they're going to be using some
combination of binomial poisson
geometric negative binomial and I want
you to see if you can find the story
that you think matches
um if that's interesting to you okay and
certainly I want you to know that you
can visualize these you can use these
equations a little gift from the TA team
to you
okay
let's start with dating at Stanford
person you date has a 0.2 probability of
being someone you spend your life with
Wow wonderful I made that number up
what is the average number of people one
will date and then what's the standard
deviation and of course recall that the
meta goal here is to think about what
steps would you take to answer a
question like this practicing the art
form of taking a question finding the
random variables and then using the
proper equations associated with those
random variables so talk about what the
person next to you you have a point zero
zero zero zero zero one probability of
that person being the person you spent
no I'm just joking just talk about with
the person next to you
something
okay
now you might be at the point where
you're plugging in equations and if
you've gotten to that point you win
right just basically you could use
there's all those equations I've written
are in Python you could just plug it
into a calculator
the goal is can you get to the point
where you know the equation that you're
supposed to be using
as I said almost always we're going to
be defining random variables when we see
new problems and this time I helped us
out I'm going to say there was a pretty
clear random variable in this question
which is the number of people that
you're going to date until you find the
one
so that's the random variable I Define
but the next step should often be tell
me about that random variable it may be
one we've never seen before and you have
to derive the probably Mass function
from scratch but ideally you can declare
that it fits one of these narratives did
somebody find a narrative that they
thought fit nicely
find the number of people you
use model as a geometric
okay I very much agree what's the
probability of success on every trial
you must give that to define a geometric
okay
its number of coin flips until you get
your first head and we're just going to
say you have a probably 0.2 of getting
heads on every coin flip now as soon as
you've done this then
you can answer these questions what's
the average number of people one will
date What's that question asking
saying what's the expectation of x
and at this point you know it's a
geometric and you can just look up the
expectation of a geometric
expectation of geometrics is going to be
1 over P so it's going to be one divided
0.25 fantastic
so 1 divided by 0.2
and then the next question is what's the
standard deviation so like what's the
square roots of the variance of x
and then again we can say you know what
is the variance of
a geometric random variable it's 1 minus
p
divided by P Squared
and the standard deviation is just going
to be the square root of that variance
so did you have to derive that this is
the equation for people that you date no
you just recognize that this is another
instance of the story we've already
learned so fantastic the learning goal
is really this then this then Define the
question and then you'll be able to look
up your equations let's take this for a
spin okay another one that's worth
thinking about this is actually an
interesting one sent to me by a student
who once took cs109
Justice Breyer who is a Stanford Alum
was on the Supreme Court and they had
this question about whether or not a
jury selection was biased and how people
chose the jury selection and
particularly they were thinking about
whether or not a minority group was
represented enough on a jury so somebody
was saying this jury was selected
unfairly because of it was completely
white and so that was what they were
discussing
and it was coming from a particular
Community where they knew the
demographics of the community
Justice Breyer hypothesized a scenario
involving
um you know well a thousand balls 60 are
blue and 940 are purple so that imagines
the the demographics from which people
were selecting a jury if you select 12
from this earn
what is the probability of getting all
of them being one particular color
uh Justice Breyer then says something
like you would expect something like a
third to a half of all juries to have at
least one minority person on them and
they said looking at this uh particular
region and looking at their history of
juries they've been clearly choosing
them in a biased way
interesting Supreme Court involves the
Stanford alumni and it involves some
probability so I suppose my question for
you guys is
sorry he says something
he invoked sorry I I didn't okay he
invokes the binomial theorem he says in
his defense he actually said this can be
represented as a binomial random
variable
so can we do that can we represent the
number of people on a jury who are
coming from the minority population as
being a binomial random variable so it's
a x equals number of people
from
minority
and he's claiming that or this is why Y
is distributed as a binomial
in a binomial
people number of people on a jury
in a binomial have to give an n and you
have to give a p
in this situation set up in front of you
can you guys figure out what n is and
what p is I'm just going to give you
guys a hot minute to think about this
think about it for a second and then
we'll think about together
okay
hopefully thinking about this you
understand that he's talking about the
number of people on the jury
so it's like you have 12 coin flips
and he's saying every coin flip you have
a certain probability of choosing
somebody who's not from the white
majority in this particular region so
what's the probability here of getting
somebody who I guess he has this story
of
uh a thousand and sixty are from a
minority
so the probability of any one person
being chosen uh who is a minority is 60
over a thousand you can then ask the
question what is the probability that y
equals zero
and I believe I wrote this up
I love writing things up it's so fun
when we get to do that oh my computer is
being slow today
not scrolling
wow we're already onto machine learning
that's exciting
Cherry selection okay
so I'm going to simulate this you know
we're going to flip 12 coins and what's
the probability that they all come back
purple is the question that he's posing
in his Supreme Court
guess it's possible to come back all
purple but uh it's certainly not that
likely
so this was the defense's argument
you're like it's just like it just
happened by chance we were choosing all
these juries and they just always came
back all white but then you can look at
the distribution of their juries and it
doesn't fit the distribution it should
have been now
this is the answer that uh
Justice buyer talked about prob it's a
binomial there's 12 coin flips every
probability every coin flip has a 60
over a thousand chance of coming up as
in his metaphor a blue coin and he says
what's the probability of X being
greater than one and you can solve that
as 1 minus probably that X is zero and
we can just use the prime minimum pmf
and it says about 52 percent of juries
should have at least one person who
isn't from the majority class now if you
just look at two juries it'd be really
hard to talk about bias but they looked
at all the distribute all the juries in
history and they said it's way way less
than 50 okay there you go there's a jury
that's not all white and you imagine
about 52 percent of juries would look
like this so very interesting very
interesting that he referred to the
binomial distribution he was wrong with
his probability he said a third to a
half but really it should be over 50
which went you know like they got some
bad math in a Supreme Court decision
kills me okay yes question
I'm so glad you asked that okay I'm
gonna just pause and talk about that for
a second
the binomial distribution here is not a
perfect story because in the binomial
distribution every time you flip a coin
you have exactly the same probability of
getting heads
and this isn't quite the case because
after you've flipped a coin here you now
only have 999 people to choose from this
probability will change not very much
because when you that dinar becomes 999
it won't be that different but it will
change over time which breaks the
Assumption the binomial so the binomial
distribution is wrong but
if you guys were curious one thing that
we don't go deep into in cs109 is
there's this other random variable
called A hypergeometric and A
hypergeometric allows for exactly this
sort of change in probability where
every time you pull a ball out of an urn
your probability of pulling that color
decreases slightly if you're really
curious to learn about hypergeometric
you would make my day and then you could
go learn about a hypergeometric put in
all the parameters from this problem you
could get the hyper geometric probably
Mass function and look at the answer you
get using the correct random variable
you get 0.5261 and using the binomial
which is a slightly wrong
wrong assumption you get 0.5241
what's the takeaway from you guys there
binomial does assume probably stay
constant so you were right in
recognizing that this was violating it
the next takeaway is if you violate that
assumption just slightly you're going to
do just fine
um and then the third one that the world
is filled to the brim with one around
wonderful random variables and someone
in this class may discover their own
because maybe you'll be doing some
research or starting a company and
something interesting will come up and
you're like huh no one's ever talked
about this particular random variable
and then you'll have your own and you
can name it after me no I'm just joking
you should you don't get to name it
after yourself someone has to do that uh
so like you would you wouldn't call it
like I don't know maybe discovers one he
wouldn't call it
distribution someone else is like not
that important
geometric random variable because
what is it's really it's not that
related to the geometric right it seems
like a hyper binomial would have been a
much much better name and that I'm
curious about too I'm gonna check us out
and tell us why is it called the
hypergeometric it's nothing to do with
the geometric hypergeometric looks a lot
like a binomial and basically nothing
like a geometric so I these people
should just name it after themselves
so okay uh long story short you can
declare a random variable if you
declared a binomial random variable with
these particular parameters you wouldn't
just know the probability of getting a
jury with zero people you would know the
whole distribution so here's the problem
zero here's probably getting one person
probably getting two people probably
getting three people you can certainly
look at all the juries that have zero
people and say that something's wrong
but you could also use all this extra
information that you have to go deeper
if you're interested okay we got the
demo
I'm going to keep throwing problems at
you so we can practice taking the real
world and finding the random variables
my next one comes from Bitcoin mining if
you guys haven't heard of bit behind my
I do not know where you've been living
but maybe you don't know the algorithm
for Bitcoin mining the way the Bitcoin
mining works is
they're going to give you this hashing
algorithm called Shaw 256 and they're
giving you a chunk of data and then you
get to choose a bit string
and when you put these two things
through shot 256 it should give you a
number back
shot 256 is going to give you a number
back that you should interpret as
basically random zeros and ones but you
win you mine a Bitcoin you get I don't
know what that's worth twenty thousand
dollars now
I think you get like twenty thousand
dollars if for a particular challenge
you're able to produce uh assault that
leads to a
um a random looking series of bits that
start with G zeros
so if G was one you can imagine like
every time you try a number you'd have a
50 chance of mining a Bitcoin but if G
is larger you'll have a smaller
probability and we're just going to
think about that a little bit you might
be able to solve some of these problems
just straight but I do want to challenge
you to think a little bit about random
variables but sometimes you don't need a
particular random variable sometimes you
can just solve it straight
real problem from a midterm in case
you're curious okay the first one
what's the probability that the first
thing you try will produce a bit string
which starts with G zeros so it's
basically asking
if you Generate random zeros and ones
what's the chance that your random zeros
and ones start with G zeros lots of ways
approaching this one certainly you could
do this one without a random variable
but but just to show you what looking at
the world like is like three random
variables let's give it a shot
in fact I'm not going to push you to too
much to think about this one because I
think a lot of you guys can just think
about look at this and say the
probability is one half to the power of
G the chance that you produce a random
bit string that starts with G zeros is a
chance that you get a zero followed by a
zero followed by a zero since each one's
independent you can just imagine
multiplying those probabilities
but I did want to show you guys being
super formal and finding this in terms
of random variables
so I'm going to say x is my number of
zeros in the first G bits
and in my world now every bit is a coin
flip it could be a one it could be a
zero
X is going to be the number of zeros in
the first few bits and therefore because
it's the number of heads and coins or G
coin flips it's going to be a binomial
where n is going to be equal to G so the
number experiments is given to us as
this number G and the probability of
getting a zero on every experiment is
0.5 and then this question is just
asking what's the probability that the
number of zeros in the first G bits is
equal to zero
and I can just use the binomial
probability Mass function which leads to
this thing that people could have
derived without a random variable
okay just a little bit of warm up
how about this one this is one where
it'd be super hard if you didn't know
about random variables
I'm going to give you guys a moment to
think about what's the problem that
you'll need under a hundred attempts to
mine two Bitcoins this answer we're
going to call probability a that's the
probability of mining one Bitcoin on any
attempt
so it's like a slot machine every time
you pull the slot machine this is the
probability of you winning
my question is what's the problem that
you'll need less than 100 pulls to get
two Bitcoins questions about what I'm
asking
every bit is going to be a zero one and
you get a Bitcoin only the first G bits
are all zeros
why can't you just like enter here oh
because you don't get to make the bit
stream you get to like basically pull
the shot 256 lever and it's going to
give you back a bit stream
equal to oh man I was just like I made
this example I brought it into slides
today and that should have said the
probably that x equals g
because if G is the number of zeros you
want to have G zeros oh man and then I
have to do all my math again but guess
what this is not going to be G choose G
and it's going to be one half to the
power of G
times one half to the power of zero
this only works out if G choose G is
equal to one but guess what if you have
G items and I say choose G items how
many ways can you do that
yeah good times okay so that does that
one that was a great question that was a
typo on the slides this should have been
equal to G
question for you guys what's the problem
you'll need under a hundred attempts to
mine two Bitcoins I'm going to give you
a whole whop in two minutes to thinking
about this don't try and give me the
number but try and do the process Define
the random variable uh tell me what the
questions asked in terms of random
variable and then we'll just think what
equation do we want to use
okay go for it
okay
I want your guys's answer to start with
this these three words you can choose
why if you don't like X but I want to
start with let X be
and then I want to define something that
the problem's asking about and it's
asking you know
um 100 attempts to mine two Bitcoins I
want X to be some number that that
question is referring to
anyone who hasn't said anything they're
like I want to share I want to tell the
world yes
be the number of Bitcoins behind versus
99 cents
it was probably you need under oh that
would definitely solve it oh my gosh
that's such a good way okay X be the
number of Bitcoins mine
uh in the first
you say a hundred what was your 100 or
99 at any times
uh okay
99 number of Bitcoins mine in the first
99 steps
this is interesting okay and then what's
the problem what's the question asking
like now let's write the problem the
probably a question like is this asking
the problem that X is the number of
Bitcoins minus first nine nine steps is
it probably that it's asking the
probably that x equals
greater than or equal to two
okay you guys let's think about this for
a second X is is a good answer slightly
different than how I approach it but I
think you might actually get to the same
answer let's double check let X be the
number of Bitcoins that you mine in your
first 99 steps
so you're saying I'm going to flip
why not a hundred
s
under 100 okay so I'm going to flip 99
coins uh every coin has uh
every coin has a probability of coming
up heads of that we've got PA and you
can say what's the problem that X is
greater equal to so then you say x is a
binomial
like n equals 99 and P equals PA
probably X is greater than two
Bitcoins or two or more
um
exactly two Bitcoins yeah
but if you find more than two Bitcoins
in 99 attempts and that means you get to
two Bitcoins before
and I think I buy that so I I agree that
has to be greater than because you could
get more than two Bitcoins and you want
to count that
I buy that that works
it's a different way than I thought
about it but I actually do think this
will get to the same answer did somebody
have a different approach for this did
you have a different random variable
declared
yes
until two Bitcoins
okay then what's the problem asking is
asking the probability that X
that X is less than 100. the x is less
than 100 okay and then finally what is X
the big reveal it's uh
it is a negative
two successes
okay where R equals two and what does p
equal
I think it's one
it's one half to the power G it's the
thing we defined in in problem a
this is how I approached it and then you
can use probably that X is less than 100
you can just use the negative binomial
equation
uh and I think this also answers the
question of why negative binomial gets
its name because I do think that is this
relationship that people are referring
to in the name but I think these are two
different solutions to the two different
good solutions to this problem yes
yeah okay um and and this should say two
Bitcoins so I've typed over there
um so let's talk about this
your question is
number of attempts until you get to two
Bitcoins X can't be zero good point also
X can't be one you can't have one trial
uh technically this this is a more
elegant solution
but technically the probability of zero
is zero and the probability of one is
zero so you'd just be adding two zeros
to this which would get you the same
number but I think this is a much more
elegant way of writing it
good good shows them Insight yes
because if the number of tries until you
get two Bitcoins if you pull it once and
you get two Bitcoins like what it's time
to be alive just like retire from
Stanford enjoy your new yacht okay
why is the the why does the Sun go up to
100 instead of 99 sloppiness
they let you become a professor even if
you get off by once
okay
um and certainly I really appreciate so
two different approaches totally fine
and two very good ways of seeing a
problem and recognizing the math behind
it
for the expanded answer for the binomial
would it just be the sum of that after
like when X is equal to two that's such
a good question how would I actually do
the next step here I wouldn't do the
probably two plus three plus four plus
five because that feels onerous I would
do one minus the probability that x
equals zero
plus the probability that x equals one
and it says the probably that X is
greater than equal to two so these are
the only two cases that don't count and
this seems like less work to do
but good question
okay
I was going to give a pedagogical pause
this is your chance to like summarize
what we learned about we have long
lectures I want you guys to have a break
so take a moment if you guys have
questions please do ask me otherwise try
and summarize we've talked about four
new four random variables at this point
try and see if you can get your head
around what they all mean okay yeah
okay
do you guys like the pedagogical
positive do you guys like having a
moment just to relax in the middle
lecture you're not okay
yeah they're long lectures just so much
probability to know
uh
we get to have a wonderful conversation
right now
we are at a beautiful point where I
really think I could give you any
discrete random variable and you could
run with it you could probably read it
use this probably Mass function and
start to solve problems and you could
really quickly go from knowing four
discrete random variables to knowing
hundreds you have the ability to learn
new ones that's what really matters
but you are missing something
and it's that not everything in our
world is discrete so if you're working
on problem set two for example one of
the things that you're doing is you do
this estimating the location of a phone
based on the distance to a cell phone
tower I think that's the very last
problem but that assumes that you can
take a two-dimensional world and
discretize it and think about all the
locations as being discrete squares but
we know that the real world is not
discrete it's in fact continuous and be
great if we can start to think about
this continuous space
and the simplest example I can give you
of the world not being discreet is this
very humble python function called
random and it exists in every language
random if you the base of a lot of
random number generators
is a continuous number between zero and
one if you call random
you might get
0.11234567 8 9 10 11.
but
there's a reason that this is so hard to
reason about
in these random variables like consider
binomial you can ask what's the
probability of getting a one back you
can ask what's the problem of getting a
two back but let's see if we can call
random
so
I think math.random
and I will make this much bigger
you know if you were generating
something with coin flips and you talked
about number of Trials you could ask the
question what's the probability that
this would return us back a two if it's
simulating the coin flips if this was
simulating coin flips you could ask
what's the problem give us back a three
oh
oh it's random
random not random forgive me
the problem when we get to the
continuous world is this is certainly a
random variable it's going to take on a
value and it's going to take on a value
you know with different probabilities
but we it's hard to reason about what's
the chance of getting exactly this
number and especially if you allow this
number to keep going to infinite
precision
I've become so painful to think what's
the problem of getting exactly this
number so even though continuous is at
the end of the day not going to be too
hard there's this one itch we have to
scratch
so
let me give you another version of that
same story
let's say the average rate of
earthquakes is one every 100 years
using a poisson we already have the
language to talk about the probability
of different numbers of earthquakes in a
year you can say what's the probability
of two earthquakes in a year you can
talk about the probably three
earthquakes in the ear
but our language breaks down when we
start to talk about how long until the
next earthquake like if you ask the
question what's the probability that
it's four days until the next earthquake
this really awful bug shows up
when you say four days do you mean four
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero days and if the
earthquake shows up one billionth of a
second later that doesn't count as being
four days
time when you think about amount of time
until an event is continuous and it gets
so hard to think about a probably Mass
function in the continuous space
now riding the bus is a fun thing I
thought this would be a fun little ride
to bring us from the discrete to The
Continuous world and to really
illuminate what I'm talking about
we've thought about this problem while
waiting for the Marguerite imagine
you're running to the bus stop and you
don't know when the next bus arrives you
have a distribution of probabilities for
when the Bus shows up
you show up at 220 what's the
probability that you wait less than five
minutes
so
um
I think you arrive sorry you arrive at
two o'clock
yeah 215. you arrive at 2 15.
and you want to know what's the
probability wait less than five minutes
forgive me
so if you arrive at 2 15
how do you think about the probability
that the bus arrives at 217 and like
infinite Precision seconds ah gets so
hard to think about but here's a hackier
thing we could do
imagine this is two o'clock and this is
205 uh and this is 210 and everything
here is a five minute chunk
if you could represent time not as a
continuous but time is broken up into
five minute chunks then this problem
becomes a lot easier to think about you
know this is the probably that the Bus
shows up between 2 and 205 205 and 210
210 and 215. uh if you show up at 2 15
the chance that you wait for less than
five minutes is just going to be the
probability that the Bus shows up in
this five minutes section
does that sound good
but time isn't broke up into five
minutes sections is it can we break it
up a little bit more and start to reason
about
this probability if we made time a
little bit more fine-grained
okay let's break it up into time being
2.5 minute sections if you break time
into 2.5 minute sections your belief of
when the bus will show up it gets a
little bit smoother
and the width of every single belief
becomes a little bit less because this
here is representing you know between 15
minutes and 17.5 minutes and this is
representing 17.5 and 20.
this is discrete we can this is a sort
of probability that we can absolutely
reason about seems totally fine if you
want to know probably wait five minutes
you just add the probably that the Bus
shows up in this 2.5 minutes to probably
Bus shows up in this 2.5 minutes
those of you guys who are fans of
calculus might see where I'm going this
like really to be honest with time we
shouldn't allow time to be 2.5 minute
sections we should make it smaller and
then we should make it smaller and we
should keep making our intervals of time
smaller and smaller and smaller until
they're infinitely small
and if you did this you would basically
have invented calculus again and you'd
be particularly inventing this idea of
integrals an area under the curve you
know your buckets become smaller and
smaller and smaller
and your question no longer becomes the
sum of the values of each of those
buckets but rather it becomes the
integral under this new curve that
you've gotten as your buckets became
infinitely small
this area is called the integral
and this new curve that you got when
time became infinitely small is no
longer a measure of probability but it's
the derivative
of probability
and those words strike fear in some
people's hearts but for other people
you're like oh what a happy place it's
going to be a happy place for all of us
uh so
as probability you know as our interval
got smaller and smaller and smaller
eventually you'd no longer have a
problem you have how much is the
probability changing when I take an
infinitely small step in my x axis
this leads to the most critical idea you
need to understand to get continuous
random variables and once you understand
this idea the rest will come quite
naturally
but this is going to take a second to
get used to when we talk about a
continuous random variable like this one
for example that can take on values with
infinite precisions
we can no longer ask the probability
that the random variable takes on a
precise number instead we represent our
probably Mass function using this other
thing called a probability density
function
the probably density function is the
derivative and if you want to find a
probability query
you're not just going to be looking up
from a probably Mass function instead
you're going to be integrating under a
probability density wow and it's going
to be just fine uh
I want to just go over notation really
quickly this probability density this
derivative is the thing that's the most
important thing to know for a continuous
random variable just like the pmf is the
most important thing to know for a
discrete random variable
okay
integrals you're going to have to do
them but they're loving not scary and
here's one of the ways I talk about
integrals in cs109 you really know need
to know the concept of integral you need
to know when you need an integral there
is wonderful calculators out there who
can do the integrals for you you don't
need to memorize all the integral
equations you just need to get the
concepts you have to get the concepts of
a derivative and the concept of an
integral that's what it looks like to be
a modern mathematician
integrals ask allow you to take a curve
and answer the question what's the area
under the curve so if this is your curve
then integral under that curve between A
and B will be written with that notation
and it will represent what is the area
under this curve if this is the integral
then this line is the derivative of that
same integral
okay so if you ask
the value of this line would be what is
the rate of change of my area at exactly
that point if this is a review for you I
would recommend just go watch a Khan
Academy video on integrals and you'll
find it just understand what an integral
is because you really want to understand
what integral is coming into cs109
so back to this question my claim is if
you really could represent a belief
distribution about when the Bus shows up
the best representation would be this
derivative of probabilities that we call
the probability density function and if
somebody gave you that to answer this
probably question we would just be
finding the area under the curve between
the values 15 and 20.
this is a little abstract so
we're going to make it a little bit more
concrete by learning about two useful
random variable types
couple things to note to give us some
intuition
if you take a probably density function
and you integrate between two points
you're asking the question what's the
problem that this random variable takes
on a value between a and b and since
that's a probability it should be a
number between 0 and 1.
also if you say this is the derivative
of the chance that this continuous
random variable takes on a value and you
integrate from all the possible
assignments from negative Infinity to
Infinity that's like what's the chance
that the Bus shows up between negative
Infinity seconds and positive Infinity
seconds
you're like one I guess assuming that
the bus ever shows up which maybe it
won't but assuming that you're just
talking about time until something
happens it will be one
so this is
a question that I want you guys to all
have baked in I'm going to ask it to you
one other time in this class and when I
ask you what do you get when you
integrate over probably density function
I want you guys to just yell out this a
probability can we try it out what you
get when you integrate over a probably
density function
oh fantastic okay so the probability
density function isn't a probability
itself is something that you can use to
calculate a probability
probably density functions they're the
how probability is changing at a certain
point in time it's the derivative so if
it's flat that means you know the
probability is just increasing the same
amount of time as you increase more area
into your query
if it goes up versus it goes down which
of these three do you think represents
the belief
that a bus is more likely to arrive
close to 3 pm so this is 2 on the left
hand side and this is 3 P.M on the right
hand side so this is 2 p.m 3 P.M 2 pm 3
P.M which of these says the bus is more
likely to show up at 3 pm
I like shouting we're just gonna do a
little bit more shouting can we all just
Shout
hey yeah in this one it says you know
probably density is relative likelihood
because the derivative tells you how
much you'd be contributing to an area
here the derivative is high over there
and low over here and that means that
this is relatively a more likely space
this means any time is equally likely
the bus could just as well show up at
zero minutes at 60 minutes and this is a
different distribution that says it's
not equally likely it's way more likely
to show up at say like 10 minutes and
less likely to show up at other points
in time so the main takeaway from this
slide is that probably density function
it's not a probability you'd have to
integrate under it to get a probability
but it is a relative expression of
belief
it does turn out that if you compare
probably density is this meaningful and
I will formalize that for you on Monday
but I just want to point that out now
okay
probability density is not a probability
rather it is the derivative of
probability and therefore it has units
of probability divided by units of X in
our case this was time
so if you look at the probability
density at a certain point you might get
that it's 0.05 and that would be like
the units would be probability per
minute it's not a probability itself
you'd have to integrate it to get
probabilities
one Cheapo way to integrate is you just
look up a value and you times by a width
you get a rectangle and if you get a
nice approximate rectangle then it's a
fine approximation of your integral so
if you look up one of these values
multiply it by a width of say two
minutes then you would get something
that looks like an area under the curve
and something that looks like a good
approximation of a probability
oh here is a wild thing which is totally
possible here is a probably density
function for when the Bus shows up what
am I claiming here
I'm claiming I am positive about
the bus that's showing up here is not
showing up here all of the probability
area under the curve shows up in this
point five minutes
but as I mentioned f of x is not a
probability it's rather the derivative
of probability and I want to point out
that that means that f of x can be a
value greater than one our probabilities
are greater than one
are probably derivatives ever greater
than one
yeah yeah it's totally possible
especially if like the width here is
less than one that would allow the
height to be something greater than one
anyways another major takeaway is just
that there's probably density is not a
probability it's the derivative of
probability
at this point I hope you guys are
feeling more comfortable with a probably
Mass function it's the most important
thing to know about a discrete random
variable it relates values that your
discrete random variable could take on
with the probability that it takes on a
value
the analogous idea for a continuous
random variable is not a probably Mass
function it's a probability density
function
and it is the derivative of how
probability is changing at a particular
assignment
because it's not a probability we use
this little F to represent this
probability density and it's the most
important thing to know about continuous
random variable this is like complete
information about your discrete random
variable and this is complete
information about your continuous random
variable
and but they're both the representation
of the relationship between values the
random variable could take on and How
likely it is to take on those values
okay and you can read a little bit more
about this definition
I'm going to give you a problem it's
actually a really cool physics problem
but I'm just going to give it to you as
a straight continuous random variable
X is a continuous random variable and
I'm going to give you the probability
density function
the probability density function for
this continuous random variable has this
beautiful equation which if you graphed
it out looks like a semicircle
I'm also going to run a simulation where
I get a hundred thousand samples of X
and I'm going to show you the histogram
my question is how would you take this
information and calculate the
probability X is greater than zero
and
let me give you three ideas and
hopefully this builds some intuition
the first idea the one that I've been
kind of hammering is that this is
complete information because you can
always integrate under it to get a
probability
so my first solution is you can say the
probably that X is greater than zero is
the area under the curve of the
probability density function from 0
until Infinity but since it can't take
on values greater than 100 it'll be the
integral from 0 to 100. so you could
just integrate this whole puppy and
you'd be like I'm going to integrate you
from 0 to 100 don't forget your DX
over here
and that's not wrong
but
while that is one approach I want to
show you simultaneous approaches that
maybe will give you some insight
you could also look at all of my samples
and you say how often were my samples
greater than zero and if you did that
instead of getting as integral from 0 to
100 you get a sum from 0 to 100 of my
histogram that'll be approximation won't
be as correct but it'll give you a
number that's just about right
and this is just for humor a third one
is you can no semi-circles realize that
this is defining a semicircle and
knowing that the area on the right hand
side has to be equal to the air on the
left-hand side and you're just like well
probably X is greater than zero is one
half
this is just supposed to be a toy
problem to get practice with probably
density functions if you guys are
curious where this comes from it comes
from quantum physics and there they
consider random matrices and then every
element in the random nature you can see
is like background noise and they want
to know what's the probability that if
you chose an eigenvalue of that Matrix
that would be greater than zero turns
out that whole thing got rephrased to
the random variable problem that we just
solved but that's not that important
right now I just thought it would be fun
to share okay what do you get if you
integrate over probably density function
you guys got it that's awesome okay
so now we have to learn two new random
variables the uniform and then we're
going to learn the exponential
the uniform is the probability random
variable for a number which is equally
likely to take out a value between a
lower bound and an upper bound so it has
two parameters Alpha and beta Alpha is
the smallest value you can take on beta
is the largest value it can take on that
random I showed you over here
it's a uniform the lowest value can take
on a zero and the highest value you can
take on a zero
the most important thing to know about a
continuous random variable is it's
probably density function which you can
use to solve probability questions and
it says how relatively likely is your
random variable to take on some value
Little X
and for the uniform it's constant
it's 1 divided by the size of the range
so the max minus the Min in the case of
the random I showed you this is just
going to be 1 divided by 1 minus zero
so it's saying the probability density
is one in all locations and it's zero
otherwise
if you had to graph this out it would
look like a flat line where below Alpha
you can't get anything above beta you
can't get anything and it's equally
likely in between that area
a couple properties you can know the
expectation if you have a uniform you
can know the variance so if you ask
what's the variance of these numbers you
got right here then I would just do 1
minus zero so that's one squared divided
by 12. the variance
of these numbers is 1 12. now you know
okay
so if this is my bus and my belief about
when the Bus shows up is uniform in the
range 0 to 30.
then what is the probability of wait
less than five minutes well I'm going to
integrate from 15 to 20 that's my
favorite range I care about over the
probably density function the
probability function is just going to be
1 divided by 30 minus 0.
when I integrate this constant just
becomes an X if you look at a wolf or
malfo you're like what's this integral
it would just give you that it's x
divided by that constant and then I
evaluate the range 20 to 15 and when you
do that you get 5 over 30.
which makes so much sense if it's
equally likely at all points and you
wait for five minutes it's equally like
to show up at any time within 30 minutes
then your probability of it showing up
in those five minutes is 5 over 30. yes
[Music]
it is not it's a probably Mass function
so the question is is this also a
probability density function if not
because it's actual probabilities
and probably density functions they're
going to look like this
oh
where their derivatives probabilities
and notice how there is no gaps you know
we're going to define the derivative
probability at every single point
whereas then probably Mass function
there should be gaps it should be more
like a bar chart
you want to find the probability of
something being less than five then also
you kind of add up
okay I'm with you so you're saying like
you still do something similar to an
integral if you want to know probably
less than five you would add this to
this to this to this this it's kind of
like you're doing an integral and that's
the Deep parallel yeah if you're doing
the probability that the discrete random
variables in a Range you're adding if
you're probably continuous random
variable range you're doing the
continuous equivalent of adding which is
integration
yes foreign
world in the continuous world only
probably density functions good question
okay I want to introduce you to one
final random variable before we call
this a day and it's the last one look at
what a day we have had we're going to be
learning about the exponential
the exponential is a continuous friend
of the poisson I think of them as best
friends I think they grew up together
they had such a good time together
they're so similar in so many ways but
they've got their own personalities
so we're going to be thinking about an
experiment that lasts a certain duration
until you get a success
an exponential random variable is going
to be the time until a success and when
you talk about the time until you get a
success if you declare it to be an
exponential you would write it like this
you say the time until my success is
distribution exponential and it takes a
parameter Lambda why does it take a
parameter Lambda that reminds me of the
poisson poisson was you know the number
of events in a fixed time frame when
there's a poisson process
exponential is also during that poisson
process it's like those Uber drivers are
showing up or those requests are showing
up and this is the number of time until
the next Quest shows up so if the
poisson says you know you have fixed
time
how many events are you going to get in
that fixed time
the exponential says how long until your
first event
so
if you declare something to be an
exponential uh for example you have time
until your next earthquake or time for
requests to reach your web server or
time until the end of a cell phone
contract time until
is the keyword for an exponential
poisson was number of events in time and
exponential is time until they're very
good friends
the probability density function is
given by this beautiful equation Lambda
times e to the power of negative Lambda
X Lambda is the average number of events
within one unit of time
and if you were to draw it out it has
this curve which exponentially decays
and there's where its name exponential
comes from
you I'm going to give you the
expectation and I'm going to give you
the variance so as long as you can
recognize something as an exponential
you inherit all three of these things
for free you're like I like free stuff
awesome
let's try this out at beginning class I
said follow along and we'll be able to
answer the question what's the chance
that I'll be four years uh until the
next big earthquake at Stanford
here's the information I'm going to give
you I'm going to give you Lambda it's
the same Lambda as a poisson that's the
average number of earthquakes per year
the average number of earthquakes per
year in California is 0.002
so
0.002 earthquakes per year
and that's your average rate
what's the probability of zero major
earthquakes in the next year you could
solve this using a poisson because of
the zero
um
all right sorry yeah what's the
probability of zero or that it takes a
whole year until the the next earthquake
but this you can also Express as an
exponential and I would challenge you to
try and express this as an exponential
think about it I'm going to clear up the
board though we're going to just look at
the answer in a second
okay if you wanted to make this an
exponential you would say uh uh well you
click okay sorry this is the poisson
version
you could say x is the number of major
earthquakes next year you define as a
plus sign you say what's the probability
that X is zero you could use your
probably Mass function
what if I ask what's the probability of
a major earthquake in the next 30 Years
now you could set up a different poisson
which are the number of earthquakes in
30 years or you could approach it as
exponential a lot of times you'll have a
choice between exponential poisson but a
lot of problems naturally lend
themselves to exponential better
my question is what is the random
variables here so probability of a major
earthquake in the next 30 Years
instead of talking about number of
earthquakes in 30 years I'm going to let
y be years until the next earthquake
now the question is just asking what's
the problem that X is less than 30 but
because I Define it as how much time
until the next event now why is an
account of events instead of Y is time
and in this case it perfectly fits the
story of an exponential which is the
time until an event
so the time until event I'm declared as
an exponential you have to give the rate
of events per unit time
and then you immediately inherit that
the probability density is equal to that
beautiful equation you could substitute
in Lambda in which case the probability
density function would be this beautiful
equation and there's an e missing here
though
now what's the problem that Y is less
than 30. that's all we have to do
and up till now these questions have
been just plug and chug but for a hot
moment this won't be just plug and chug
because is the probability density
function a probability
it's a derivative of probability if you
wanted this one we have to solve this
integral
it's the integral and the range of the
values we care about over the
probability density function that gives
you the probability that y will be in
the range of 0 to 30. let's go there
okay you need to know this integral
review you need to go the integral of e
to the power of c s is equal to 1 over c
e to the power of c x e is such a
beautiful thing to integrate in which
case when you took this integral
you would get uh you know Lambda times 1
over Lambda e to the negative Lambda
um and you would inter evaluate this in
the range 30 to 0. once you have the
integral you just plug in 30 into this
number subtract off plugging 0 into this
number and you would get 0.06
. who looks forward to doing in an
integral every time you have to do a
continuous random variable problem
well I was like yes awesome
um okay
um I just want to show you one mother
question and then I'm going to show you
a beautiful thing about exponentials
that will make you tear up it's so
beautiful
why is the number of years until X
earthquake
um what if I change my question to the
expected number of years
until the next earthquake
so now I have the same y it's still an
exponential but I'm no longer asking
what's the probability that you get an
earthquake the next 30 year instead I'm
asking what's the expected number of
years in which case you would just use
the expectation of this new random
variable you just plug in that formula
if I ask you the variance of years until
the next earthquake you would just use
the variance formula
okay standard deviation yeah exactly you
just say here's my exponential and I
want the variance I get that and then a
standard deviation is just going to be
the square root I'm just looking up this
formula like why do I know that this is
the formula that's because if you look
at your exponential
that is the formula for the variance of
an exponential
now I want to leave you guys with hope
so I want to talk about how you can
solve these problems without integrals
I'd like to introduce you to a great new
friend who you can bring on your
wonderful probability Journey with you
welcome everybody to the cumulative
density function it's not a probability
uh it's not a probability density it's a
cumulative density and it's not right in
PDF it's written as a CDF
and it's a special thing the CDF which
we write as a capital f represents the
probably the random variable is less
than the input to the CDF so this is a
function if you put in a 0.5
to this function it will return you what
the probability that your random
variable is less than 0.5 so it's a
function that's where the F comes from
and if you learn how to use a CDF you
may never need to do an integral you may
need to know what an integral is but you
might not need to use it it has this
shorthand I will often try and just
write it using the normal notation
okay it's a function you put in values
and it gives you back probabilities
particularly the probability that your
random variable is less than that value
here's the CDF of an exponential
so it's got this nice closed form
equation you could have derived it you
could say I want to derive the
probability that X is less than Little X
you could start with the integral over
your PDF in you know plug and chug and
when you're done you'll have derived
that the probability that X takes on the
value less than Little X is this number
but how could you use that
let's try answering a few questions
using both the PDF and the CDF
so this is a plot of the CDF
of my exponential and this is a plot of
the PDF
sorry it looks like there's a little
slideshow decide to give me a little bit
of excitement for a second there
what if you want to ask the probably the
x is less than two
there's two ways of solving it you can
solve it using the PDF and you can solve
it using the CDF if you wanted to solve
it using the PDF you'll do the thing
that we've said like a hundred times in
this lecture you would take the integral
from 0 up to two under this curve
you would use a integral but can you
solve this just using the CDF recall
that the CDF is defined to be the
probability that X is less than whatever
your input was what would you put as an
input just yell at me
yell at me confidently
yeah it's two if you just put a 2 into
the PDF you look up this value and it
directly answers your question if you
just put a 2 into the formula for the
PDF of an exponential
you would just have to put in Lambda and
your 2 and you would get a number and
you would get the same number regardless
of how you solved it now obviously it's
good for answering questions when of the
form probably X is less than something
but what if probably is greater than one
again using the PDF we can calculate the
integral calculate the integral from 1
to Infinity under that curve go or is
there a way that we can use this
beautiful friend the CDF to solve this
problem
one minus yeah if you just look up the
value at one it'll give you the probably
the x is less than one if you want the
probably X is greater than one you just
do one minus that value you're done and
you didn't have to integral like look at
this you're laughing you're having a
good time the person is doing this tears
the person using the PDF tears all the
way and the person uses CDF just having
a blast but then the PDF has their
Revenge because obviously this question
is easier to solve with a PDF the new
question is what's the probably the
random variables between one and two
and here the PDF just like I'm going to
integrate like I always do what does the
CDF do
an idea subtract subtraction
you look up
the value at 2 and you look up the value
at one the value at 2 is the probability
that X is less than two and the value
one is probably the x is less than one
if you take the probably that is less
than two and subtract off the probably
that's less than one it's like you're
taking this integral and you're
subtracting off this bit which just
leaves you with the purple bit in the
middle CDF can solve all of these
probability questions which leads me to
the final question of today what's the
probability of a major earthquake in the
next four years
well it's an exponential but I'm going
to use a CDF I'm just going to ask
what's the probably this lesson four
it's a CDF of four I'm just going to
plug in this nice little equation and
you get that there's a 0.008 probability
of a major earthquake in California in
the next four years I'm feeling lucky
hope you guys are too that's the end of
today's class have a fantastic week if
you have more questions come ask me
afterwards and see you guys back in
class on Monday